now at 22 years old I've seen things I
have gone through things and I have been
places in life where a lot of people
don't go you know I've got a lot of life
experience in in these areas and I
should you know why should I am from
Texas
Fort Worth well really Granberry so
really it's a town outside of Fort Worth
but I ran around Fort Worth it it's
probably what most people would
recognize both of my biological parents
I had a good childhood it was just me
and my younger brother we're eight years
apart so when I was younger I grew up in
West Texas and it's around Midland
Odessa area it's a town called crane
with a population of about
3000 people my school class is 75 people
so everybody knows everybody and
everybody knows your business so when I
was in elementary school I was acting
out I threw fits and I had really bad
mood swings never with anybody else I
wasn't bad in school or anything I had
straight A's always the top of my class
but I was also by the time I was in
third grade I was a little overweight so
I got bullied a lot at school and the
bullying went on for so so so so long it
it got to a point where by middle school
I didn't even want to go to school I was
yelling at my mom and you know they
thought I was just being rebellious but
you know I just didn't wanna I don't
want to go to school where people were
just gonna yell names at me and but um
by the time I was 13 I started cutting
and that was something that I did
because I wasn't very I am I it wasn't
very fond of myself you know I I dog
through so many things by then that I
just I didn't care much for myself my
self-esteem had already plummeted before
you know I even had a chance to try and
start
but as far back as I can remember I've
always just had like a deep hatred for
myself I just never thought I was good
enough and you know how come I'm five
years old and I I don't I don't really
like myself you know I hate that I'm not
I'm not cooling off you know I think
that my cousins think they're better
than me and which in fact they did it
you know I had a great cousin I had
always played together but I just never
thought that I was as loved and there
was no there was no explanation that I
could give myself for that so I have you
know I thought scars on my arms in my
leg that went on for a really really
long time and sometimes it still happens
today and I'm 22 so and I started at 13
when I was in sixth grade I had two
friends and that slowly went down to one
and then it kind of was hard because I
didn't really know who else saying elf
is everybody at that time like I said
there's 75 kids and they've all had
their own little groups and my friend
the two friends I had slowly started
drifting apart again the bullying was
still there
the cutting was getting worse the fits
were getting worst and that is when I
stopped trying in school the cutting by
then had gone super bad that I then been
diagnosed with depression and mood
swings they want thinking when you're
younger they don't label you as bipolar
because they don't want to do that to
you they want it's because you don't
think they'll able to have so they put
mood swings and my anger issues and
things like that
but by then my dad had got a job and
they were gonna do like a six-month
trial to see if they liked him or not
and I told my mom dad like I want to go
please can I go with him
so me and my dad moved to cranberry and
that was when
I went to a new school and this school
was just so looking a lot bigger and
they're like when I went when I moved
there I remember kids trying to make fun
to me because my you know as Mexican the
I wasn't very many Mexicans that's
that's a mess and they were cracking
jokes saying that my dad was a gardener
and that do they be like are usually
equal no I mean I was born in Texas and
I wasn't on the volleyball team so and
also again I was still Chucky so I had
never been
what's it like I never had at that point
had had a real friend and you know
that's really all I wanted but at the
same time I've kind of wanted to be cool
and trying to be popular in a way but
the effort I was making more an engineer
because you know I didn't want it I
don't know what to do
I was like trying to look up diets on
the internet and things like that but it
just didn't help I was just I couldn't
do it but by the time it was October I I
had got I started to get bullied there
too I AMS and that was the first time
that I really started to be suicidal
I wasn't sure like what to do anymore
because at that point I really had no
friends not even friends that we're rude
or mean to me I just it was just me and
we went down to West Texas to visit my
mom my little brother and it was my
birthday and
sorry that was the first time that I
tried to kill myself
sorry I'm a one kind
um but I remember
telling my mom and dad like you know I
made a mistake I don't want to go to
that school anymore can I please come
back
[Music]
and they won't let me because I had uh I
tried out for the school musical that
AMS and even though I was the new kid I
got a part I wasn't aware that I could
sing and feel like I went to choir class
game and I remember I got bullied
because I got a part in the musical but
I tried to kill myself right here I have
scars from it so I had to go get
stitches but I had to go back to us to
AMS back to Granberry and I just cried
and cried and cried and cried and then
that weekend that I had got back a
couple days later I I tried to commit
suicide again and I cut myself again the
same place it's just his other one
beside it
and you know my dad found it Tom found
me and he took me to the hospital
and I had to go so first trick that I
had to the loony bin so I got admitted
to a hospital called Millwood and
I was in there for about five days is
one of those like emergency crisis
situations where they admit you right
away that things started putting me on
pills
and I didn't like the bills because it
they weren't really working and they put
they kept wanting to do more and less of
this and more than that not this pill
and they take this pill with that feel
in that bill with this pill and it just
I I didn't like it I was going to when I
would have my like checkups and for my
physicals and stuff they would say that
I was overweight I was borderline
diabetic that if I didn't get put on a
diet immediately and I was gonna have
diabetes so I think food was like at
that point my coping skill food and then
you know cutting and then they took out
food so I was just at that point for a
fourteen-year-old girl
I shouldn't have been feeling you know I
should
I just shouldn't have and I wish that I
had
love myself more I think it would have
had a better impact on me now you know I
think that I was a lot stronger than I
thought I was but because of everybody
whispering in my ear I do not allow
myself to try I didn't know how my self
to be someone or wanted been someone
because I was afraid of what everybody
else said um so after that I did that
little five days and you know things
didn't get better when I got out you
know it's the first time I had seen my
dad cry only time I've seen my dad cry
I really love my dad you know I love my
mom but
you know they they just didn't know what
to do they you know you have your
daughter and you see that they see me
and they look at me and I'm hurting and
they think I won't tell them why I won't
talk to them but they see you know what
I'm doing to myself and I know that even
to this day that it just it hurts them
and it took a lot from my family you
know because it wasn't just me going
through it I put them through it you
know we all went through the storm
together but you know I'm thankful that
I had them because you know it I
couldn't imagine what it feels like to
have parents that don't care to have to
have to go without you know because
that's not something that everybody has
you know even most of my friends only
had one of their parents and then a
stepparent I did
so
moving on to ninth grade I was still
chubby oh yeah my cutting was still
there I had had to think of two more
trips to another loony bin and it was it
was okay but I wasn't really trying to
talk to them or get better by then I had
gotten to a point where I was very cut
off from everybody and when I would take
my anger out on my family I'd go home
and you know I would just throw it all
you know very destructive my mom told me
no I would throw stuff yelling punch the
wall and slam the doors and just because
I was hurt from school and that was when
I had stopped going to school so much my
mom had to call like the cops come get
me from my house and escort me to school
and she eventually got a letter in the
mail that I had to go to court for
truancy and it was just you know it's
crazy because she was like they said you
know if she misses one more day you're
gonna have a fine and she has all these
credits that she needs to get or she's
gonna fail and she's gonna be held back
so that was why I moved to another
another school it was called premier and
it's one of those self-paced schools
where you do like packets booklets and I
had to go there because if not I wasn't
gonna pass and when I got there it was
it was a really laid-back school and not
too many people and I started you know
making friends there I had one friend
there and she was really nice you know
and we're still friends to this date but
there was this one guy there that I
liked and you know there everybody talks
to each other because it's a small
school and most of the people go there
because they don't want to go to the big
school just like I didn't for you know
bullying reasons or behavioral issues so
I wouldn't say outcasts all go there but
a couple of them so by then I had
started liking this guy and he was a
couple years older than me and we've
been talking stuff and I hadn't go to
summer school to end up finishing my
credits so I was really surprised to see
he was also in summer school so my
little 15 year olds heart was loving I
was ready and I remember he started
sitting with me
really cool and he snow
and I had never done drugs before and
you know to me that was a no-go no drugs
at all
if you did drugs we couldn't be friends
anymore like I'm sorry I just wanted
weird right
now that I hear but I remember him
asking me to go to the bathroom with him
so we could roll the joint smoking and
you know I'm all super nervous I'm like
oh I don't know what do i do what do I
do and we go in there and he's has to go
to the stall and I'm like I was like why
do I have to go to install like you know
no one no one's here we're in like a
whole different part of the school you
know the teachers don't ever come over
here and I just go just go just in case
someone with me and I get in there and
like waiting and he's like just hugging
me and I'm like where we gonna like roll
this cuz we have to hurry up is we
already supposed to be at school he's
like it's okay don't worry about it and
he starts to like pull me closer and you
know I'm like okay because like you know
I never really hooked up with people or
never dated anybody you went down to
kiss me so I started kissing him back
but he started to get like aggressive
and I was like and he wanted to like
grab on my pants and a button and I
wasn't trying to do that so I would like
push him away
he would keep like well like so I try to
like move his hands and you know I told
him like you know a virgin I don't I
don't I'm not ready and by at this point
I had they say my ass that I was going
to wait for marriage and because that's
just what I was raised doing
my parents both waited for each other so
that's you know that's what I thought it
was and of course I grew up with my mom
telling me you know if I really like you
they really love you to wait for you and
I you know I kept telling him no when he
he was like he just kept telling you to
be quiet and no you know get off of me I
don't want to do this you know whatever
I don't want to I don't want us to do
drugs anyways so just leave me alone and
he pushes me up against the wall and
there was like a rail right there so I
hit this rail on my back and I'm like
hey what are you doing like get off and
he just tells me to shut up and he hit
me you know huge right there Jax me and
I I stopped well you know I never been
hit before and I remember just like that
incident like that that feeling like I
was like oh my god you know
it's not busy and so I'm like at that
point I'm crying and I'm like can you
please stop and you just wouldn't he
kept throat grabbing on me and feeling
up on me and and kissing me and I didn't
want to kiss him so when he kissed me on
the mouth
I just would sit there you know and he
told me the young a toilet and I I I
didn't want to you know I I was like
starting to yell at him and I was like
please don't and he started hitting me
like on my legs and on my side and he he
just pushed me down on the toilet
and when I did that I just I plopped on
there and I looked at him and I I
remember just asking him like you know
please don't do this and he didn't care
I'm he's told me that if I didn't be
quiet he was gonna hit me again and you
know that hurt
I you know I I shut down so I I just let
happen
i I remember once he was done he left me
in the bathroom and I just sit there and
cried
I remember I was scared because I was
bleeding and I
you know I Ivysaur my face was hurting a
bunch of me after that you know I didn't
have self-esteem to begin with like I
said before and that guy just destroyed
me
the very last bit of self-worth that I
had I didn't have much at all you know
and having for him to take and I
remember them talking about
me I mean you know made me want him to
testify and I couldn't do it
detectives were calling and calling and
you know stopping by the house and
asking questions and I just wanna talk
about it want to relive it why do you
think I'm popping pills you know so by
then I had started after that I started
smoking weed and I liked it you know I
thought okay this school isn't bad and I
was like with that why am i dumping all
my friends for this yes just weed and I
remember it was it was August so I'm
almost going to 10th grade and that's I
started losing weight because of the
pills and because I started starving
myself
you know I didn't I didn't want to eat I
didn't want to do anything like that so
I also dyed my hair red and you know I
felt a lot better I started I guess
because I was smoking you know I I had a
little bit of a friend that I had
actually gotten a boyfriend he smoked so
he started getting me into smoking weed
and his friend was talking to my friend
Lacey and you know we'd all just hang
out at the summer school they'd come
over to my house we go to the beach it
would be smoked in I'd finally felt like
I had a place
you know like I had people that cared
about me so it rolls around to the first
day of sophomore year and turns out that
that boyfriend that I had cheated on me
oh yeah I was destroyed you know I was
like Marin - it's tough but it's gonna
be over with
like when why my school grades were done
for over with like I I had put zero to
none of any effort into school I didn't
care anymore all I cared about was
hanging out my friends getting out of
school I could just Park in Smokey's I
hadn't gotten into any
I was really mad that I couldn't get
into school but I mean so I was
basically a high school dropout well
yeah I am a high school dropout and
stupid because who drops out on their in
their senior year so I had gotten this
new friend and he's kicking we're still
present today but me and her have been
closed because we have gone through some
of things and we both have super strong
drug addiction she became my writer diet
was always being her and we were always
driving to the plug's we were always
doing drugs and one day we had a talk
that he was in October if we ever got
the chance to try heroin we were gonna
do it and we were gonna shoot it that's
just what we said you know a done deal
if it ever comes around okay cool and
ten minutes later someone calls for a
ride to Fort Worth to get some heroin
and that
now they look at it that's not a
coincidence
you know how do we speak something and
then there it is you know and we're all
excited we're ready to go and we drive
and we'll get it and I don't know this
guy had had a cast on and he had told us
and he just got off the hospital because
he got an infection for shooting us and
I'm sitting here like hell until now I'm
getting real skeptical and we're driving
over there and we pick it up and I
remember like watching him try and try
and try and try to hit and I was just
like oh you know what I can't look at
him because if I look Clement as chicken
and I so we waited till we got back to
in case so we could both do it and I
remember him you know
just watching him cook it up and put the
pot and suck it up and I'm like mom you
know and he ties my arm and he's like
are you ready and I'm thinking this is
hurt you know because when you see Lee
needles advertised it's like heroin
advertised it's always like I need a
listing when really they're just this
big and I remember I just stuck my arm
out I looked away and I read when I
looked and I use are you good I was like
yeah and I watched it and he said lift
your arm and I completely like flopped
over
I wasn't OD'ing I just I nodded off
really hard and I was like yeah guys I'm
okay just leave me here I'm good I'm
good linear and I remember the song that
was playing with Hollywood dreams / -
come down by post cool and that is my
favorite
and I remember feeling like I was
floating and everybody asked me what
does heroin feel like and I tell them it
feels like heaven but it always turns to
hell
after a while you know I remember
telling my friend Xenia tried to see you
to try this out me and my close group of
friends I had it all started doing
heroin and you know I didn't know the
impact I was gonna have on their lives
asking them to try this to try shooting
up just this once just this once it
became just this weekend okay just just
this week after this we're done just
next month next month and we were all
don't be violent and we were all getting
in trouble by our families we weren't
supposed to be hanging out with each
other because we were obviously doing
bad things we I had started Pawnee
everything in my house I don't have I
didn't have anything and then my parents
didn't have anything anymore you know
like have to go into a pawn shop and
pick everything back up and they started
hiding everything from me
by then my family and I we would already
have the problems because of my
behavioral issues so now I had added a
drug addiction as super hard work and I
didn't know what being I didn't know
before heroin that I was a drug addict
but that is when everything became like
just full-blown for me I tried to get
away from it and I couldn't I found I
ran to Colorado I moved to Colorado and
I was in the middle of the mountains two
hours away from Denver where I had to go
get it and I was going driving through
the snow and everything just to get it I
ended up falling in my staircase in the
apartment I had and I had sprained my
wrist and my friend found me in there I
was unconscious and
I haven't been him into the hospital and
I lost my job because of my drug abuse
and I came back to Texas I went back to
Texas and I started smoking a lot of
crack love right definitely left correct
but it's not the best thing to do but it
was it was fun me and my friend had a
good time all it you know it was fun to
have someone to go along with you to do
that because drug addition becomes an
isolating thing by then
it was just I didn't care you know I I
just wanted to get high I started dating
my drug dealer and yeah he was 27 and I
was 19 at that point and then my friend
KK went to jail so I had nobody it was
just me by myself and nobody wanted
hanging off me because I was a needle
junkie then by the time after that I had
started abusing meth really really bad
and this was 2000
17 I started abusing it really bad and I
I was I stayed up for 12 days not like I
had a little naps in between but I I was
seeing [ __ ]
I was hearing things like I was just
what the heck and by then I had by this
time I'd already been to rehab 11 times
who goes are we have 11 titers nobody
but my parents of course sent me and had
to go or had to go how to go ahead and
go how to go I hated rehab I thought it
was a stupidest thing I thought inning
was fate I just painted everybody I just
wanted to do drugs and I want everybody
to leave me alone and I ended up getting
arrested because car had gone out on
bond and pecking out on bond we went and
on November 25th I got arrested at
Walmart for stealing yeah and I was the
yelling at people in there cuz I'm skits
and so hard I was like it's looking at
this people like if we're gonna talk
[ __ ] talk tell us my face like what am i
doing and I stole a phone
I stole a bunch of other extra stuff and
I was walking out the door and this big
big security guard like this big runs
and he scoops me up and so he picks it
up and I'm like what the [ __ ] he puts me
in this back room and they searched me
and they send me to jail and I am so
high they found all of the phone I think
like a candy bar some headphones speaker
and then a dub of cocaine so I went to
jail my mom tried to I call my mom she I
want to get me out the reason she want
to get me out was because I had gotten
into a dangerous situation with some
people that I should not have been
hanging out with
I'm not gonna go to introduce all about
that but just because it's it's not
something that needs to be talked about
but
so my mom thought me being in jail they
were protected she's protecting me
people had like you know hacked into my
phone and things like that and and we're
watching me stuff like that so it was
kind of scary so she left me in there
for that reason and also because I
needed to sober up and that was when I
started withdrawing I was like oh my god
like in jail they don't care about you
unless you're dying then they'll
probably maybe give you a nitro fin
maybe but after that I got out of jail
and I was like you know I signed for
probation I had time I could do time
served or probation but at 19 I didn't
want to be a felon so I signed her
probation I'm not even a month after
being in jail I got pregnant so I didn't
know I was pregnant until four months
afterwards by then I had already started
doing heroin you know I did heroin three
hours after I got out of jail Oh three
and I started abusing heroin Hart and
cocaine hard again and again and by this
time I thought I was pregnant I was
already physically dependent doctors
told me that if I stopped immediately
there's a chance that like my baby's not
gonna make it
and I always thought I'm gonna have an
abortion I swore up and down if I ever
get pregnant it's a board mission no
matter what but when I saw him you know
he was in there he was moving around me
like little like that was their little
arms and I heard his heartbeat I
couldn't
my son today is 11 months
he's the best thing that ever happened
to me I ended up signing a felony
because I went to jail four more times
or probation violation but I got into
rehab when I finally found help I got
put on methadone because I you know I
didn't want to lose him and a lot of
people talk [ __ ] on me because I've got
on that medication and when he was born
he was addicted to methadone and they
had to wean him I got a lot of a lot
disrespect for it but my son was born
not breathing
so he you know I thought I felt
something was wrong in the operation
room they gave me a c-section cuz he
just got stuck
uhm and I knew I felt dead but I thought
it was me I thought I was dying and I
was okay with dying because I knew my
son was gonna be okay with my parents
when he when I finally got to see him he
was covered with twos and he couldn't
touch him because he would be scared and
he was like you know they had to bring
him back even he's like shocked and I
remember spending every single day at
all hours of the day in that NICU I
slept there in the waiting room I and it
was the hardest thing I've ever had to
watch
and I promised myself I would never ever
ever touch heroin again I'm so scared
[Music]
I can't take care they can't even take
care of myself and I I tried so hard you
know and I ended up relapsing two months
later in March I had six months clean I
never tried to get clean before you know
I was really I was doing good I got it a
new car
I had my son my family trusted me to do
what I wanted you know what I wanted as
long as I came back you know I went to
NA meetings I did all that and I really
just took care of my son and I really
like I love being a mom by then they
were gonna they were gonna take my son
they told him they don't my mom they had
to take him he had to be removed and it
was either me via my parents house or my
son be at my parents house so I left I
was dating a man who was older than me
is 43 and he had money and I manipulated
him into giving me a lot of money for
drugs and you know I had way too much
drug money I I just went off the wall I
went on the run for a while got picked
up by bounty hunters and things like
that
so I got a giant August I signed for the
felony in the misdemeanor and I got
tired of using you know I I have been in
a relationship me and say well he broke
when we broke up
he I broke up with him for another guy
the guy was dating was a heroin addict
who also like to shoot a pair I wanted
cocaine I really I really loved this guy
still do we broke up his past
we broke up in October but he he really
changed a lot for me like you my is my
perspective on things yeah he was my
best friend
I loves talking to him just being with
him we lived together and he showed so
much love for my sidon you know he
wanted me to do better and I just you
know I just kept doing drugs and he kept
telling me you know you gotta stop you
gotta stop you gotta stop
and because he wanted me to get my son
back he had one day we had got in a
really bad argument because it really
been important but he had started
hitting me not really everyday not a lot
like that like it was just like little
thought why are you doing that don't do
that you know but this time it was like
really heavy he poured a Gatorade bottle
on my head
like called me all these mean names and
spit on me and tried to keep me but you
would have hit my face but I was already
trying to go down you know I was just
banging him to please stop like you know
you can't hurt somebody like this when
you love them and he went and he got it
done you know I just remember begging
like I just prayed
you know because I didn't know he had
uncle Gaiman and they when he does
cocaine he is really angry I just like
prayed to God like please not hey you
know I have my son's out there right
here but after that we broke up and then
I decided to I'm moving in with his plug
because he told me that I was a nasty
[ __ ] and I told him I bet your plug
doesn't think so and I ended up moving
in with his plug he was really nice to
me you know they treated me like they
know me my whole life you know they
helped me out they never once tried to
sleep with me I never saw them you know
they took me on for my birthday to a
casino they took me out to the club you
know I had a lot of fun there but it was
down the street for my ex-boyfriend so I
was starting problems and I wanted to
get clean so of course I called my eggs
the one that the 43 year old and he had
ended up moving here to LA to get away
from me he says but I called him
absolutely some helmet if I need to get
me into rehab he said yes I get here and
I don't bring any heroin with me no type
of opiates no sandboxing no nothing cuz
I'm like ready to do it
and
got here and oh hell I was not ready to
do it when I started kicking out was
just like no no no no no so I went out
to find it and I knew and you know what
maybe ask the homeless guy he'll get it
for me right he's got a no and he did
you got it for me and I was doing that
and I'm still living I was living on
Hollywood Boulevard and say he the guy
ended up kicking me out because he knew
I was using drugs and I was like
whatever I'll come over here I had no
idea what Skid Row was I didn't know how
bad it was and I end up living over here
on 7th and I just I was like okay well
I'm homeless okay like there's a bunch
of other homeless people right and I'll
the hill taking him back eventually he
still hasn't even he was Judy cuz I
didn't want a relationship with him and
that's what he thought it was gonna be
so being here I've been really hard I've
only been on the streets for three weeks
and I
I ended up being kidnapped because the
people I trusted the guy person I was
living with in a tent he let me stay
there with this girl that I was I liked
and he set me up he got paid I don't
know how much probably not a lot like a
couple bucks and this man abducted me
why do me I sent me he said he was doing
waiting where she's gonna part i sat
down and he was I close the door I'm
like I'm good you know and ended up
striving up and I'm renewing what are we
doing you know and he's like no we're
gonna we're gonna stay in this
neighborhood we ended up you know in the
beginning it was cool you know I had my
stuff yet he said I was like okay cool
we're just talking it wasn't that bad I
was like sorry I was a [ __ ] to you I'm
sorry you know I'm just I don't trust
people out here um well we ended up
going to a hotel and he says he's gonna
bring me that never brings me back I
have no idea where we are there's no
phone in the hotel room there's no Wi-Fi
you know I told him in the beginning I'm
not having sex with you I'm not a
prostitute I don't do that kind of stuff
you know why I'll have sex for money or
drugs and he did not give a [ __ ]
he tried to play that card I really
liked you I really liked you wanted a
want to be with you Bobo blah and he
ended up taking advantage of me
and
I'm sure because nobody knew where I was
out here on these streets you know if I
don't make it
well you know what if I just don't come
you know I know my mom doesn't know
where I am
only have one first thing out here okay
keeps in contact with my parents not
even really in contact with my parents
and calling you know because he lives on
in Homewood and I remember just thinking
like if something happens to me my
parents are never done no buzz never
gonna know what happened
I'm still on heroin I've used a lot of
meth lately because there's not cocaine
knowing it I know that okay now there's
somewhere I just haven't found it that
is why I'm super super skinny and I have
clams helmet back on my shore her money
I do boosting which is something that a
lot of people do out here but really if
I'm being completely honest I really
just have been blessed in a lot of ways
with a lot of people
care for me you know
who have helped provide me with shelter
and that made sure that I'm not sick
made sure that I eat and just watch for
me no and I don't I don't think that
everybody gets that because I've seen
some girls who who are out here by
themselves you know I thank God every
day for for those things because every
hard time that I've gone through my life
God had put someone in my path to help
me whether it's the detox nurse in jail
somebody that is have to store or
another homeless person so I think that
all in all I want to go home
you know but I'm not allowed to right
now because my son is there as of today
I have contacted my mom I've made plans
to go home and go to rehab so that I can
get my son
because this is not for me this is the
place where people come and they get
comfortable living the way that they are
because they they have drugs you know
and here it's easy to be homeless it's
not easy you know it's more
uncomfortable because there's a whole
bunch of other people I want something
for myself I don't have again my
self-esteem right now sucks I don't I
hate just every bit of what I'm doing
and what I've done I don't want to be
yeah I don't want to be this person I
want to be a mom I want to take care of
my son I want to be I want to make my
parents proud I want to make myself
proud so I'm not going to stay here
anymore I'm not gonna do it and I know
everybody says that but I'm not I'm not
gonna be like everybody I'm gonna just
I'm gonna change I don't I don't want
this life anymore I don't I don't want
to be in and out of jail I don't want to
be on the streets because the streets
you know you hear all the time these
streets are dangerous but when you
actually live on them it's a whole
different story so
all righty
good luck with your recovery and getting
back to your cell